What am I about to tell you
cannot be repeated to anyone
I have a greater purpose than any
of us could have ever imagined
your fiance is hope for the
world what about it going on
we haven't seen the world so you don't know
you keep going for family
I'm not family
no your cargo
say who you can save oh please understand
saying it's a virus some kind of parasite is it
from terrorists I don't know are we sick no of
course not why do things blow up cell phone no
radio News man one shut up how do you know what
now you know we're not sick well which terrorists
dumping with Federal because it's where you'd be
safest and you were safe there until you decided
to sneak out a terrorists was Riley a terrorist
if you have a greater purpose than
any of us could have ever imagined
so we're leaving tonight
and we're taking you with us
count slowly and clearly from one to ten one two
three slowly and clearly one two three four five
six seven eight Welcome back everyone it's Charlie
The Last of Us episode one is out this week on HBO
I'll be doing videos for all the episodes just
like I did for House of the Dragon so be sure to
subscribe to get them all it's based on the video
game and it's probably one of the best video game
adaptations to series that we've gotten thus
far we can only pray that the God of War series
gets the same level of treatment as this Pedro
Pascal plays Joel who you remember either from
the Mandalorian or Game of Thrones another Mega
HBO series The Mandalorian season 3 episodes are
actually going to overlap with the last couple
of Last of Us episodes just a little bit and in
a funny twist like you can make all kinds of
jokes about this both of the characters start
out on glorified fetch Quest protecting super
important small young characters like grogu and
Ellie I'm not family no your cargo Ellie is also
played by another Game of Thrones Alum the little
bear Bella Ramsey so lots of Game of Thrones Alum
on this series but it's HBO so it makes sense the
series largely follows the plot of the original
video games they also just tease that they're in
the middle of making the last of us three or that
there's more story to tell and they won't go past
the video game story so I think their plan is to
make like four or five seasons we'll see if they
go beyond that they're not planning on covering
the story from the entire first video game during
season one I haven't seen all the episodes but
I believe they'll split the events of the first
game across season 1 and season two they've added
a few non-game characters to fill out the universe
a little more and go deeper on some of the groups
during the story during some of the bigger parts
I'll be sure to point out the big ones in my
episode videos when they appear the biggest brand
new character not from the video games that are
in all the trailers is Kathleen played by Melanie
Linsky who's the leader of a revolutionary group
in Kansas at the core of the series Joel has to
carry Ellie all the way to the other side of the
United States they started in Boston so there's a
bunch of groups that they encounter on the way
they did bring back the original voice actors
from the video games for special roles the voice
of Ellie in the games is played by Ashley Johnson
she's playing Ellie's mother on the show you
see her in some of the trailers she's holding
tiny baby Ellie which will show you that they
are going to have some flashbacks to explain
the origin of the fungus Joel was originally
voiced by Troy Baker who's going to be playing
a villain that they haven't revealed yet if
you haven't played the games The Last of Us
is a post-apocalyptic Series in the same vein as
The Walking Dead Or station 11 set in the not too
distant future about 20 years after a big virus
outbreak with a type of fungus called cordyceps
which is meant to be a real type of fungus like
that does exist in real life when Neil druckman
created the video game story he said he wanted to
base it on a real world scenario like something
that could potentially happen during the story
in the year 2013 there's a viral outbreak of this
mutant strain of the fungus that goes complete
full-blown pandemic like we just saw a couple
years ago talk about PTSD turning everything
into a what you see in the present day of the
trailer like the zombie virus in The Walking Dead
Universe except fungus covers everything and turns
everyone into slightly different creatures they
are kind of like the walkers on Walking Dead but
they're called clickers because of the clicking
sound that they make they also move really fast
too unlike the walkers from Walking Dead but
it's the same basic premise the show gives us
a much bigger flashback to explain the actual
origin of the fungus at the beginning of the
show the first episode is like a full 90 minutes
once the present day of the show picks up about
20 years later in the year 2033 they might have
moved this a little bit for the TV show because
it's only 10 years in the future at this point
but when the main part of the story picks up
about 60 percent of the world's population have
either been killed or turned into clickers in the
fungus covers pretty much everything in sight it's
universally contagious if you go near the clickers
get wounded by them the fungus gets on you that's
it you're done there is no cure but as you see in
the trailers they discover that one girl Ellie
is seemingly immune so the the fireflies a group
of survivors that oppose a group of the other
survivors controlling all these quarantined
zones that humanity is grouped in try to smuggle
LA to another group of scientists working with
them in a different part of the United States
so they hired Joel who just a Smuggler For Hire
just like a regular guy trying to survive in the
apocalypse he'll do whatever anybody pays him to
do highest bidder doesn't really worry about it
doesn't really care and a big part of the story
is Joel looking for Redemption through Ellie's
character just because of all the Terrible Things
he's done in what happened to his family at the
start of the outbreak you do get a flashback to
explain what happened to him at the beginning he
lost his daughter in an accident at the beginning
of the outbreak So eventually he starts being less
of a dirtbag and Ellie kind of grows on him the
same way that grogu slowly grew on the Mando like
Mando started out as kind of a dirtbag character
morally gray kind of character eventually his love
for grogu in wanting to protect him turned him
into a much better character same thing happens
with Joel and Ellie the difference between Joel
and the Mando though is that Joel Still does
a lot of really terrible things like way worse
stuff than the Mando does but the whole idea is
that the death of his daughter years ago at the
start of the outbreak just completely broken and
he slowly kind of becomes whole again in caring
for Ellie eventually she starts to think of him
as a surrogate Father Like I said there's going
to be all kinds of memes and jokes about grogu in
the Mando while the show is going on as he tries
to smuggle Ellie across the United States to this
other group of fireflies they encounter a bunch
of different people both good and bad and through
the sacrifices of a bunch of different people he
starts to care about her one of the connections to
a show like House of the dragon or Game of Thrones
is that on the show pretty much everybody does
terrible things like there's no Saints on the
show everyone's just trying to survive in the
apocalypse I mean it's kind of like walking
dead too like you just have a lot of people doing
really terrible things to try and do their best
to survive do what they think is right but each
person having opposing views about what they're
supposed to be doing next and opposing views about
what Ellie should be used for like what value does
she old as a person if she could potentially be
a vaccine is she nothing more than a cure for
scientists to use like a glorified lab experiment
how does Joel continue to protect her if that
means preventing Humanity from using her to create
a vaccine one of the other big differences from
The Walking Dead is The Walking Dead never really
bothers to ponder where the original zombie virus
came from there were all kinds of questions about
that when the show started they never spent any
time trying to explain the virus itself there were
people that lied and said that they knew what was
going on with the virus but they never actually
explained it on the show whereas the last of a
series is all about that and they have the Cure
theoretically the whole time in Ellie so it's on
Joel to prevent outside forces other groups even
the fireflies themselves who are supposed to be
the good guys from using LA to their own advantage
or taking advantage of her as he would protect his
own daughter just like House of the Dragon a
lot of the people that say that they're the
good guys are definitely not the good guys and
do really terrible things Joel himself also in
trying to care for Ellie be a surrogate father to
her winds up betraying a lot of the people that he
also cared about mostly because he grows to care
more about Ellie than about the rest of humanity
which also kind of creates a lot of theories about
the Mandalorian season three will the Mando care
more about grogu than he cares about becoming a
true Mandalorian again I don't want to get too
far into the video game Last of Us story because
I don't know how far they're going to go during
season one but like I said some theories they
plan on doing four to five seasons of the show
and they'll split the first game into the first
two seasons Neil druckman kind of pulling a George
R Martin saying that there is more story to tell
like there's lots of other stuff going on here
in this universe that we could tell but they won't
go past whatever the final game winds up being but
it does sound like they're going to make the last
of us three that would give them potentially like
five six seasons you can go out right now and
play the video games and learn what happens the
games have been out for a long time and they're
fantastic I would definitely recommend checking
the games out if you haven't but a lot of season
one will just be Dirtbag Joel eventually looking
to find some form of redemption in caring for
Ellie in Ellie who's still very young during
the events of the first game as she is during the
series slowly coming into her own and learning to
survive on her own when the story picks up she's
still pretty helpless and speaking of Mando and
grogu the Mandalorian season 3 trailer is actually
supposed to release on Monday right after the
episode comes out so like I said big Crossover
with Pedro Pascal on both shows here of course
I will do a video for that on Monday when they
release it my episode 1 video should post late
on Sunday night I don't know what their plan is
for season two my assumption is if they can finish
it in time they'll try to get it out by the end
of 2024 next year because we're talking about HBO
too they're in the middle of prepping House of the
Dragon season two it'll start filming really soon
I'll do more videos for that series as well but
those episodes won't be released till next year in
the Mandalorian season 3 episodes are starting at
the beginning of March we'll get a couple trailers
for that before it starts the other big series
that will be starting in a couple months will be
Marvel secret Invasion series with Nick Fury based
on comic book secret Invasion with the Scrolls we
do have the Super Bowl coming in a couple weeks
there'll be a bunch of trailers for all that stuff
at the Super Bowl as well you can click here for
my full episode one video I'll update the link on
Sunday night as soon as I post that and click here
for my house of the Dragon season 2 teaser trailer
video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!